almost 75% of self-made billionaires
were in direct sales Mark cubin told me
he was selling garbage bags door too
Elon Musk every night at 900 p.m. he
would call all the sales managers in the
entire United States and teach them how
to sell Bill Gates at age 16 was on the
phone selling computer stuff he would
lower his voice so they couldn't realize
he was a team like oh this is uh William
Gates and he was doing phone sales I
call it the king of all skills the king
and queen direct sales and marketing
these billionaire guys they're tough
negotiators that's sales man my
millionaire friends you can be like you
know what let's do a deal that's fair
for both of us oh not a billionaire he's
going to extract that last penny out of
you you better read a contract sent to
you by a billionaire I'm going tell you
that right now you better not celebrate
cuz they shook hands with you and said
we're going to do the deal that way they
will change the deal 5 seconds before
it's over I'm dealing with one of that
right now